Doki Doki Oh welcome back to Doki Doki
literature club we are on day four in
the game day three in real life
director yuri is still the best girl but
you know i'm getting more than more
charmed by these other wonderful women
what am i saying this is the part where
everyone is like now the game gets
really messed up Poots it's been really
hard to avoid spoilers i here's another
thing people want me to play with the
game files open everyone is telling me
hey you have to do you have to play with
the game files open otherwise you're
missing a lot I'm gonna do that just I'm
gonna keep it in my peripheral I got
pretty good peripherals don't you worry
but yeah let's just keep playing and our
last save was Monday
13:36 it's time for us to write another
poem where's my goddamn steam library
there you are
steam apps common doki-doki there we go
alright I'll keep it in there and keep
an eye on it
death oh she likes theft so you have to
pick what what they like maybe we should
try in romance and Matt Sookie okay well
I guess oh wow
I am terrible what Natsuki sorry
Erie
[Music]
who likes philosophy that's her any like
clumsy oh she's clumsy of course in
intellectual that's her um dark that's
her what tenacious that's her I remember
that unrequited not get Jim of course
that's her damn the music's kid
crimson that's her I remember that
melancholy utter horror that's her OOP
no there we go we did it
we done deadly doodlee batted oh man oh
man I'm the way no way that's not her
voice I'm the last one here again Monica
is such a thought
don't worry I just walked into
where were you practicing piano again
yeah sorry ah ha ha ha you must have a
lot of determination starting this club
and now picking up piano
well maybe not determination but I guess
passion remember that the club wouldn't
be here if it wasn't for all of you and
I'm super happy that you're all willing
to help out for the festival too I can't
wait for the festival
it's gonna be great sorry I mixed up
nuts against a hurry before uh hey
weren't you complaining about it
yesterday Natsuki well yeah I'm not
talking about our part in the festival
but it's a whole day of school where we
get to play neat all kinds of delicious
food you sound a bit like sorry all the
sudden Monica do they usually have fried
squid squid that's a pretty specific
thing to look forward to oh come on are
you saying you don't like squid you
animal people what is this conversation
hey I didn't say I didn't like it
besides what do you mean by you of all
people because it's right in your name
mom I think ek is squid in Japanese
am I wrong am I wrong I'm wrong hey hey
hey Monica that's not how you say my
name at all also that joke make no sense
in translation
ah nevermind let's just focus on our own
event for now okay fine fine
your reactions aren't so as far as you
recent say or eise anyway she likes to
provoke as opposed excuse me where is
Sayuri anyway oh there you are
Sayuri is sitting at a desk in the
corner room looking down at nothing I
walk over to her hey Suri I waved my
hand in front of her face hey you're
spacing out again to me me you can go
talk to any with ease huh
is everything all right okay wait
wouldn't it be it just feels like you're
a little off sorry for assuming same
things you worry too much you paid me
insane
sorry shows me a big smile don't break
different having fun with every week
well alright if you say so
I worriedly glance at say re before
turning back towards everyone else but
the conversation has already dispersed
with everyone back at their usual
activities maybe I should ask Monica if
she's notice anything about saiary
recently since they've been preparing
for the festival they must be spending a
lot of time together i timidly
approached Monica who is shuffling
through some papers at her desk
pizza pie what's up hey this might sound
a little strange but have you noticed
that anything would say ori lately
anything up with her in what way do you
mean maybe I'm reading into it a little
too much but she seemed a bit downcast
today oh you think so I can't say I
noticed anything about her Monica
appears across the room at Sai or E who
is idly dragging a rubber eraser up and
down her desk doesn't seem like Sayuri
to me
maybe there's something on her mind but
I'm surprised I'm not the one asking you
kids pay you certainly know a lot better
than I do yeah but she's never really
liked this she always talked to me about
things that bother her but this time
when I asked her she was really
dismissive sorry I know it's not your
problem I just wanted to ask if you know
anything so I'll drop it now no no it's
important to me too I mean I'm also
friends with her I also care about the
well-being of my club members
you know she sounds like such a robot
maybe I'll try talking to her myself are
you sure about that
she seemed like she wanted to be left
alone are you sure
maybe she's just having a hard time
bringing it up with a person of interest
person of interest what do you mean by
that I'm saying that maybe the thing on
her mind is you Peter Pan
[Music]
what me
how on earth could you come to that
conclusion well I probably shouldn't say
too much but she already talks about you
more than any anything else you know hey
hey she's been so much happier ever
since you joined the club it's like an
extra light but it was turned on inside
her what no way Saira is always like
thing she's always been full of sunshine
it's not any different now than I was
always been
you're so funny pizza pie have you
thought that maybe you always seen her
as so cheerful because that's just how
she is when she's around you ah I said
too much I'm sorry what do I know anyway
I didn't mean to jump to the conclusion
so just forget about what I said I'll
try and talk to her so try not to think
about it for now
Hey all right Monica smiles meaningfully
I know she I know she said to forget
about it but I already know that I won't
be able to get at her words out of my
head Monica sends up from there her desk
and walks across the room to where
Sayuri is sitting i watch her kneeled
down next to Saori and gently talk to
her but she she's keeping her voice so
quiet that I can't hear from here I sigh
and sit myself down I notice I already
told me not to worry about her and to
have fun with everything else everyone
else but that's impossible to do when
she's behaving like this exactly how
much do I care about her that I'm
letting this weigh me down so much now
it feels like I'm the one behaving out
of ordinary but there's nothing I can do
besides wait for Monica why does it feel
like I'm being watched
I glanced around the room suddenly I
notice you're appearing at me from her
book
what is going on here but she looks away
just as quickly with a flustered look on
her face I realized that she won't get
anywhere like this I never really seen
you RIA proach anyone or to start a
conversation on her own accord so I have
no choice but to approach her myself by
now it's a little easier for me to do
that I stand up from my desk and I sit
in one one next to her room her own I
guess it's because we roll my story we
get to I didn't mean to bother you or
anything relax you didn't even do
anything but I could tell up what
happened
oh you can hide there I could tell that
you wanted to be alone with your
thoughts alone with my thoughts my
thoughts how were you able to tell that
I was thinking like that
well it's something that I do a lot so
it wasn't hard for me to spot based on
your posture and expression and not that
I was staring or anything I didn't do
anything creepy like that in any case
you were right I'm sorry if I cost you
any concern don't apologize
your troubles are only the concern of
those who willingly shared in that
concern of course there are certainly
those who find the most comfort in
keeping to ourselves but if you would
prefer to share what's on your mind then
I would be glad to listen it's really
not that big of a deal I was just
feeling a bit uneasy by saiary Sayuri
yeah she seems a little off today but
when I asked her about it she didn't
want to admit it to you to me Wow
the drama that tension the action are
you keeping up with this my god so I
can't help but wonder if something
happened to her
I'm checking the game files nothing has
changed as far as I can tell
oh that's quite romantic
hey Sammy mess say I didn't mean to say
anything stupid back na it's not it's
not that just what you do I didn't want
you to misunderstand Sierra and I have
been friends for a long time that's all
I see we are just friends
then perhaps it's unusual for her to be
dismissive to you about her feelings or
she gets it or maybe I'm just reading
into it a little too much pizza pie the
world is full of meaning often hidden
deep beneath plain sight and there are
many untold mysteries behind every
person no matter how well you may know
them ah so you think that there might be
something behind this after all
mm-hmm I think that saiary is a very
complex person
her mannerism on the outside don't
always match what's going on inside her
head and she may not always know what
she wants I noticed her strange behavior
today - I also feel some consent for her
but in any case it looked like she was
fully occupying your thoughts wasn't she
well I guess that was the case
saiary she really means a lot to You
doesn't she i
[Applause]
hagas but you don't need to put it that
way we're just good friends that's all
hmm you're a son who looks deeply into
my eyes her expression is gentle and
curious as if she was searching for
something embarrassed I avert my gaze
begun thought sometimes a person's
mysteries are untold even to themselves
and you as someone honest and caring
may uncover feelings you weren't aware
were in you that is I think that she
would be a very fortunate person to have
you feel that way about her could this
whamon be a little more into us my god
Yuri
you've given me too much credit I'm a
pretty simple guy so I think I'm pretty
good at understanding my own feelings
I'm not nearly as sophisticated as you
ah that's not a compliment is it that's
what it is anyway as long as we're here
why don't we do some reading well as
long as you're okay with it yeah
it should it should be I should be
taking my mind off this whole thing
anyway we don't know why don't we go
ahead and get started
yes let's actually I have a request
do you mind if I make some tea first not
at all baby thank you very much
if there's one thing that can make my
reading time here any better it's a nice
cup of tea not to mention for yourself
as well
Yury stands up and makes her way to the
closet I follow and watch her ass as
she'd retreat wait what I should be to a
small water pitcher from the shelf the
kind with a filter inside can you hold
this for a second sure Yuriy hands me
the water pitcher and also fetches an
electric kettle I'm going to plug this
in at the teacher desk and then we'll go
get some water she walks past me and
sets the Cal down on the teacher desk I
simply watch her movements simply simply
to my surprise the way she moves really
contrasts their speaking mannerism
especially because of her long legs URI
appears elegant and a methodical okay
may I have the water pitcher Thanks I'll
be right back
I might as well walk with you yeah why
not
shall we go then yeah
hmm where are you two off to uh don't
cut me right now we're just we're just
going to make some tea so I suddenly
realize how weird it sounds to explain
this to Monica we're we're just we're
just filling the water pitcher oh okay
sorry I was just a bit curious that's
kind of a one-person job isn't it big
and thought that's Monica please mind
your own business for once or do you
want me to tell me that there's
something wrong with helping involved
Paige Spain's club activities hey my
mouth gapes I I suppose there's nothing
wrong with that then let's go pizza pie
uh yes you're pretty quick Lex is the
room and I follow once in the hallway
she suddenly puts her forehead against
the wall I spoke without thinking how
could I say something like that Yuri I
just something about the way she'd said
that it made me feel so irritated what's
wrong with me no Yuri I think you did
the right thing I wasn't expecting it
but it's also not right for Monica to
judge people like that
eep-eep how come even when I do
something bad you're being so nice to me
because nothing that you do is just bad
as you make it seem in her head
nobody's perfect
we have emotions we can't always hide
behind them and may way [ __ ] I can't
read but you always amplify things in
your head your mind turns a light rain
shower into a hurricane
No wouldn't you hate me for something as
terrible as that why would I hate you I
can't hate someone for having emotions
what kind of friend would do that friend
you say jury lifts her head PTP I really
like being friends with you
thanks Yuri I like being friends with
you too
I feel kind of awkward saying something
like that but I'm doing my best to help
you refill better anyway ah yeah shall
we go yeah Yura and I walk to the
nearest water phone once we fill up the
water pitcher we return to the classroom
[Music]
pizza pie do you like long tea uh yeah
anything is fine hey when you read sets
the temperature on the kettle to 200
degrees that must be Fahrenheit
[Music]
water can't boil to 200 degrees it turns
into gas now it's time to get the teapot
you really oh yeah I read that like you
really do this properly don't you of
course I shouldn't do any less when I'm
making tea for others even if I'm not an
expert on tea or anything
uh-huh in that case you'll only be even
more impressed is she trying to impress
me with tea ah perhaps I will
Yuri fetches the teapot and begins
measuring the tea leaves to my surprise
she even starts humming a little to
herself you must be in a good mood now
he said so I was letting it show and you
noticed I was doing a bit of thinking
and he decided that I would try
expressing myself a little bit more that
is so weird
it turns out it's not very hard for me
to do when it's you who is around anyway
ah that's great Yuri just don't push
yourself too much you're always worrying
about me P to pay it's very endearing
that's Yuri wasn't kidding I don't even
know if I can keep up with this i watch
your i watch your rapport a cup of tea
for each of us pizza pie
I have another request do you mind if we
sit on the floor today what
why sy it's a little easier in my back
you know I have such large
tea I can read with my back against the
wall rather than bending over at my desk
oh sorry I didn't realize no worries I
just had back pain fairly regularly so I
do my best to manage it is that so I
wonder why that is it's most likely
because my ah my your posture right
always hunched over like that while
reading yes I have terrible reading
posture that's why we were we should sit
on the floor fair enough
I'll go ahead and get the book I'll
retrieve the book from my bag ah I have
some chocolate as well it's this bag of
small chocolate candies that I kept
hidden from so you're a scanner reader I
take it since it'll go well with the tea
your and I sit against the wall tea cups
at our sides as if in sync we assume the
same reading position as last time each
holding one half of the book except this
time our bodies are even closer to each
other I can't see too well
Yuri slides closer until our shoulders
are touching how am I supposed to focus
on reading like this Yuri was always
kind of cute but when she's being less
apprehensive it's almost more than I can
handle
your tea cap Yuri hands me my tea cup
holding it with my hand
that's not holding the book I in a
position that makes it even harder to
focus what is this position
huh because now I need to worry about
making sure I don't accidentally touch
her tracks meanwhile URI hasn't heard is
a single thing she where just her
intense reading expression and I can
only presume the world around her has
faded away I use all of my willpower to
focus on reading after a few minutes I
manage to relax a little
I put the tea cup between my legs and
fumble with a chocolate wrapper ah sorry
I briefly let go of the book to finish
opening the wrapper you can have as much
to see one ah
that's that's okay I won't take any are
you sure well if I touch it then he
might get smudges on the pages ah you're
right I didn't think about that my bad
no need to apologize I'll hold the book
okay are you sure of course
now why that's now your reopens to book
with both hands she holds it so that I
don't have any harder of a time reading
it but as a result her left arm is
practically this is why you can hide
them in he practically resting on top of
my leg well in that case URIs already
totally focused on reading again I take
a chocolate candy and pop it in my mouth
then I take another chocolate and hold
it up to URI
she doesn't look away from the book she
simply parser live as if this situation
was completely natural but that means I
can't stop here
i oppressively close the chocolate in
her mouth just like that
URI closest her lips over it Hey yours
expression suddenly breaks did did I
just hear looks at me like she needs to
confirm what just happened um pizza pie
Simmi messy I guess I shouldn't have
done that
oh that's well you were just helping
that's something that friends do right
I mean not really in this kind of
context but yeah yeah that's all it was
not at all my metaphorical penis
[Music]
yeah then you don't need to stop or
anything I see the situation has gotten
really tense URI tries to return to the
book but I can tell just by her
expression that even she can't focus now
my heart is pounding
I nervously take another chocolate
between my fingers but this time you're
his eyes meet mine how did it even come
to this URI doesn't avert her gaze I
noticed her chest rising and falling to
the rhythm of her breath
I raised my arm like before URI parts
are lips but it's different this time
I take the chocolate and place it in her
mouth and I feel her hot breath on my
finger okay everybody Monika just
getting you hot okay everyone ah your
results back it's time to share poems
pixie pad can you help Europe put away
the tea stuff right yeah of course
okay thanks the spell is abruptly broken
ah I'll take care of the cups yeah URI
picks up the tea cups from the floor I
pick up the bag of chocolate and in the
end we hey singly clean up without so
much of a word between us I get the
feeling this is something neither us
will have the courage to bring up it's
the favorite time of the day it's time
to read some poem Hey
finally let's check in on Sayuri I'm
really curious about her poem well she
looks chipper it's nice
come on I can already tell you don't
like it well you don't need to worry
about a thing
after all you wrote this for someone
else didn't you probably hurry hey I
didn't write this for anyone
specifically maybe they really wait a
minute oh but it's okay you're making
new friends just like I was hoping they
makes me really happy and you're happy
to read in this clip well of course I am
okay it's a big marriage to me Thank You
PGP Harry is there something wrong all
right just tell me if you need anything
[Music]
if you insist sayuri-chan Monique a we
sincerely we're lucky
[Music]
before I can say anything else sorry
cheerfully walks out of the classroom
humming to herself what is going on with
this whamon I'm checking the game files
I don't know
let's do nots again next me I guess do
you really haven't learned anything
after all honestly I don't know why I
get my hopes up in the first place what
I didn't even think this one was bad
what did I do wrong
poems don't need to be all deep sounding
to express something don't go don't it's
going to just sound like you're forcing
it Alice you really don't suck at it
honestly don't bother trying to write
poems like this until your immutable I
guess since we're trying to romance Yuri
our poems is reflected as such and
that's why she's critiquing it I'm
kidding I'm curious if she would like it
more if we tried harder in their own
thing anyway mastication stops short all
of a sudden don't don't tell me you're
not just trying to impress Yuri are you
[Music]
what are you talking about I and keep
your voice then you know Yuri would love
this kind of this is angsty just because
she's a talented writer doesn't mean I I
mean looks like I'm in trouble
I saw much struck a nerve though what I
did is beyond me I am so done with you
that's the gate shoves the poem and I
handed her back over to me take your
stupid poem if you brought it for
someone pills just don't show it to me
ouch this is what I get for letting our
younger girls step in my business unless
that was a mind-reader I was destined to
be in a world of pain from the start at
least not to get wasn't really the girl
I was trying to impress in the first
place let's check in on Yuri this is a
lot quicker than the other ones we don't
even read their poems this time I guess
they because we had to get another one
for the festival
PG pay to riding his old has only
improved in these last few days every
poem you shown me has been nothing short
of spectacular I can really feel the
emotions I'm a little envious even I
don't think I ever it ever came to me
this naturally Yuri that's the wrong way
to put it
this never did come naturally to me but
I've been able to improve so much thanks
to you you really the example I was
chasing is that so
Yuri gently smash to herself this
feeling I'm so glad I got you you got
the chance to share my writing I never
thought it would feel like this I
remember you mentioning that yesterday I
can't believe that you're so good at
something and you never even shared it
with anyone it's kind of a shame maybe
but it's not like I really had a choice
what do you mean
well Yuri smiled sadly pizza pie during
lunch time I eat by myself did you know
that it's a great time to find a quiet
spot and do some reading in fact I
always have some books with me
you could say I really enjoyed reading
well that's one way to put it anyway but
books are so full of amazing inspiring
people people you want to fall in love
with or people you just know would make
a really good friend cheerful people who
always put a smile on your face or deep
thinkers and problem solvers who
discover the mysteries of life so when
you look at it that way I'm surrounded
by friends every day you know and those
friends don't laugh at me
they don't tease me for spacing out all
the time they don't make fun of my body
type and
they don't hate me for acting like I
know it all people say that about you
I'm not a know-it-all appears you pay
it's the opposite I don't know anything
I don't know how to talk to people I
don't know how to make people see me as
normal I don't even know how to make
myself happy I have all these feelings
and all I can do with them is read and
write but it wasn't until now that I
started sharing it with you that I
really understood what was missing all
this time but I haven't really done
anything no she came s just being
patient and respectful that's really
important to me I know I'm a difficult
person pizza pie I speak too slowly a
second guess myself all the time I read
too deeply into things but every time
you always treated me just like anyone
else it's so rare that I feel
comfortable with myself when I talk to
others but that's why every time I talk
to you I just feel really happy I see
well I treat you how you deserve to be
treated Yuri and if other people don't
see it that way
screw them I mean I joined this club
hoping I would make friends and I would
say add at least one success wouldn't
you if you put it that way yeah we
really are friends now aren't we
Yuri put her head in her hands but this
time she's smiling as she does it do you
want to show me your poem
yeah I do let me get it for you
Beach a Marvel millions of years in the
making where the womb of earth
chaotically meets the surface under a
clear blue sky an expense of bliss but
beneath grey rolling clouds an endless
enigma the easiest world to get lost in
it's one where everything can be found
one can only build a sandcastle where
the sand is wet but where the sand is
wet the tide pens will they gently lick
it at your foundations until you give in
or will a certain wave send you crashing
down in a blink of an eye either way the
outcome is the same yet we still build
sandcastles I stand where the foam wraps
around my ankles where my toes squishing
through the sand the salty air is
therapeutic the breeze is gentle yet
powerful I sink my toes into the
ultimate boundary line tempted by the
foamy tendrils turn back and abandon my
peace to erode at the shore drift
forward and returned to earth
forevermore that was beautiful
and I'm aware that the beach is kind of
an inane thing to write about but I did
my best to take a metaphorical approach
to it yeah Natsuki already told me about
it she did she didn't say anything weird
did she she just wanted us to write
about the same topic again I suppose
it's better to compare the differences
in our writing styles or thought
processes anyway was her idea knowing
her it's not a surprise do you want to
do something like that she probably just
wants to show off it's not like I have a
particular interest in her writing style
I just went with her request but well I
suppose it's not bad to write something
about something simple on location okay
I can't be refreshing you know it's good
for me to come my thoughts once in a
while yeah I think I agree thanks for
sharing
[Music]
we got Monica left the Thark one I
wonder why we didn't get to read the
other ones poems hi pizza Peck have you
thought about what you want to submit to
perform at the festival well well
being in this club is one thing but
performing in front of a bunch of people
I'll have to give it some more time okay
no pressure but whatever you do I'm sure
it will turn out great it would also
make me happy to see hahaha
anyway let's take a look at today's fun
sure I'll let Monica take the poem I'm
holding in my hands this one's good a
fist it feels like you're not only
getting more comfortable with your style
but the imagery it's better than the
last one I read just wondering but have
you finding inspiration endurance
writing style hmm I guess so I can't
deny that she's talented yeah totally I
think our problems are the most romantic
that's the best way to describe it
she's like a totally different person
when she picks up a pen I noticed that
too or when she's talking about
literature it's like light turn and
light turns on inside her mm-hmm sadly
it's hard to get much passionate
conversation about her trust me I'd
tread who knows what goes on in that
head of hers I hope you don't mean that
in a bad way no of course not
just I just mean that I wish she didn't
keep so much to herself but still
defending her like that you must be
pretty into her you can pull you
completely misunderstood hahaha calm
down I'm just kidding besides I made
this sure she's already got a boyfriend
excuse me wait really yeah a fictional
one anyway money can't kind of whispered
that last part to me it's just a hunch
but well that's not really anything
wrong with that
all right men have wifeís women have
responders oh well I don't know I was
saying anyway I share my poem with you
now all right all right
the lady who knows everything and all
tell tells of a lady who wanders earth
the lady who know everything a beautiful
lady who has found every answer all
meaning all purpose and all that was
ever thought and Here I am a feather
lost adrift the sky victims of the
current vernon rand day after day I
searched I searched with little help
knowing legend don't exist but when all
else has failed me when all others have
turned away the legend is all that
remains
the last dim star glimmering in the
twilight sky until one day the wind
ceases to blow I far and I fall and I
fall and I fall even more gentle as a
feather a dry quill expressionless but
the hand catches me between the thumb
and the forefinger the hand of a
beautiful lady I look at her eyes and
find no end to her gaze the lady who
knows everything knows what I'm thinking
before I can speak she responds in a
hollow voice I have found every answer
all of which amount to nothing there is
no meaning there is no purpose and we
seek only the impossible
I'm not your legend your legend does not
exist I'm with it
I'm with the breath she blows me back
afloat and I pick up the gust of wind I
couldn't keep up that
my headphones fella yeah I couldn't keep
up that that ridiculous voice cuz it's
such a beautiful poet you know I feel
like learning and looking for answers
are the sort of thing that give life
meaning not to get too philosophical or
anything but it was kind of on my mind
so that's what I wrote about I see I
never really put much thought into it in
a way it's almost paradoxical because if
we have all the answers when the world
start to lose meaning makes sense her
poem reflected that you know there's one
thing I notice it seems like everyone in
the club prefers writing about things
that are more sad than happy are you
surprised
I mean if everything was okay we
wouldn't really have anything to write
about would be humans aren't
two-dimensional creatures I think you
know better than anyone
I mean you mean one-dimensional oh yeah
that
two dimensional foreshadowing Monica's
the one that breaks the fourth wall
anyway here's Monica's riding tip of the
day if you are ever too shy to share
your branding sites because you're
afraid it's not good it can be really
disheartening to get a loop on response
to something you put so much into but if
you find other people who enjoy riding
then sharing becomes a lot easier
because instead of just telling you that
you're running is good okay are bad they
want to focus more on everything that
went into it and the things you can
focus on it's much more encouraging that
way and it will make you want to
continue improving it's almost like
having your own little literature club
don't you think that's my advice for
today thank you for listening okay you
three we're all done sharing perm right
why don't we start figuring out hold on
a second it's is it just me or did you
say something strange if now
I thought I thought she left that's why
she was returned referring to us three I
didn't know she was Hey
something did sound a bit unusual that's
right you deviated from your usual catch
fresh when addressing the club
[Music]
catchphrase I don't have a catchphrase
Jeeves
why is the moon so weird today look even
you risen immune to it stagnating air is
coming foreshadowing to that something
terrible is about to happen
are they foreshadowing the foreshadowing
faces many layers in your books maybe
look the only thing different is that
Sarah isn't here
ah it seems you're right say you're it
always helps lighten the mood a little
bit doesn't she it's almost like
everyone this balance it's run off a
little which is not a rare where the
heck did she run off to anyway I thought
she just wanted to pee
netiquette please show some decency come
on
well she wasn't feeling too well and
went home early is that so
I hope she's all right seriously of all
times not to go home with her you picked
the time when she's not feeling well so
much for you two being all lovey-dovey
uh no first of all stop my sister
understanding my friend she would say
Aria and second she's kind of been
avoiding me today so I didn't want to
force it huh that curious expression
coming from Yuri out of all people come
on gasps I tucked her Ireland everything
was fine
wait what did she say anyway we need to
figure out the rest of the festival
preparation so let's sit aside what
everyone will be doing this weekend I
already know I already know what I'm
doing that's right Natsuki you'll be
making cupcakes but we might need a lot
of them and different flavors can you
handle that all by yourself not Sookie
chao-li accepted and as for myself I'm
going to be printing and assembling all
the purge of pamphlets Sayuri will be
helping me to sign them and as for Yuri
Yuri
you can guys can you have me come up
with something for Yuri I am useless and
then no no that's not it ah you're the
most talented person here you know
and now Nessa keep adding tier G's even
I can tell now I guess I never gave
Sayuri enough credit but I can tell
things are even harder on you when she's
not around
ah I may be the chess but I can't also
be a leader on my own then I won't grow
as a person if I can so you're a
you have a beautiful handwriting you
know so you should make some banners and
decoration to help set the atmosphere
atmosphere um about that I I love that
mystery yours expression suddenly
changes as she stares at our desk in
focus and starts nodding to herself your
mind is already racing I see that's
great
it'll be wonderful happier II but anyway
that just leaves you Pizza peg the one
who is truly useless
hahaha don't say that in fact above nuts
again Yura have some political have
attached to handle especially Yuri if
you know what I mean it would probably
go a long way to give one hand one of
them a hand you could always have me out
as well
[Music]
sorry I spilled drink on Edgar
I would be really appreciative of that
ah that's uh is Mona again suggesting I
spend the weekend with one of my club
members how on earth are they going to
respond to a suggestion like that ah I
suppose I wouldn't mind a bit of help
[Music]
well even if you don't know how to bake
there's always some dirty word I could
give to you it's not like Monica gave me
a choice and you wouldn't be sitting on
your body anyway not sick it tries to
mumble a bunch of excuses like that
um if I recall netsuke you mentioned
that you would like to handle the bacon
on your own while URI is really trying
hard Angie my man look at that a pizza
pie may not like a bit to be around you
if you only make him out to be a
nuisance so therefore he may be more
suited to assisting with the decorations
oh I never said that how hard can it be
to make a few decorations anyway sounds
more like you're making excuses for
pizza pie too
what are you saying it would be
extremely meticulous work and breaking
effect
just what do you think okay guys guys
let's set down for a moment in the end I
think it's up to pizza pie to decide how
he'd like to contribute
besides yes and really got the chance to
spend any time with me yet you know and
now I'm sure he's interested and
literally just said I'm surprised as
well sorry sorry
hey I was just saying the chase
can we just shuttle this already yeah
pizza pie you're okay with this right in
the end it's up to you
uh of course
very well in that case everyone's
looking straight at me of course I'm
gonna go with
[Music]
I don't know Natsuki because he might be
fun you know I everything baking would
be really fun
say Ori because she was feeling bad and
I promised her that if it comes to it I
would pick her over Yuri Yuri because
you know I want to [ __ ] and Monica
because she's a thought what'd I just
say I think I should go with sorry but
we can always go back and change don't
worry if you don't like the option and I
think Ken hinted at this ken told me
like oh yeah something's gonna happen on
the weekend you don't really have to
play it you'll know what I mean and I
was like okay if it's gonna be with
anyone then I prefer helping Sayuri I
mean we're already neighbors and but
Monica said Monica said that so Yuri was
helping her Jace do you really hate us
that much no no no sorry I didn't mean
for this to be difficult oh oh
[Music]
we're gonna have to pick my girl well I
probably be mother it'll probably most
useful helping at URI me are you serious
but I want you nuts okay I can already
tell you're about to say something me I
was just seen so you'll be helping URI
then pairs the pair yeah that's what I'm
gonna do what I have a bad habit of
overthinking these sort of things so I
think your assistance will be very
useful that's great to hear
Natsuki and will you be able to handle
beck and by yourself I mean yeah I
already said it would be fine okay okay
everybody can tell the netsuke is
feeling a little sour so is that
everything we needed to get over go over
yeah that would should be about it are
you guys excited well excited may not be
the right word Arnie
it's a horror game how is this a horror
game but I suppose I'm looking forward
to a little bit do you feel the same way
a pizza pay me I guess you could say I'm
interesting to see how this turns out
that's good enough for me well about to
you now what about you netsuke that's
icky what why is everyone yelling at me
I didn't even do anything and no that's
not what I meant at all ah
Yuri anxious a glances between everyone
in the room I'm sorry for this I don't
really know why he did see pie pick me
and also your cupcakes are the best
cupcakes I ever had they go really well
with my tea and nothing that I do for
the event will compare to that so so I'm
kind of surprised threw away well I'm
the one acting immature I already know
that but you're trying to cheer me up
all the sudden I know I'm not very good
at it I'm sorry if I said something bad
netsuke isn't the only one surprised
Monica and I are also taken back by your
his word when she already has trouble
with words trying to cheer someone up
must be far out of her own comfort zone
but I begin to understand Yuri was
trying to sound like say Yuri even if it
doesn't work perfectly I can tell she
tried to say something say her he would
say at a time like this because they
already always helps everyone smile and
feel good about themselves but I can't
do appreciate it I'm sorry for making a
big deal out of nothing but I'm going to
say this you better bet that my cupcakes
are going to be the best part huh I
believe you yeah I hope to see everyone
do their best but with that there's
nothing Marfa today so I guess it's time
for
us to head out all right let's get out
of here then everyone packs up their
things I start to follow Monica and
that's to go out the door I say chat
between each other huh
hey I turn around I'm a mess I realized
that I don't have any way of contacting
you this weekend oh you're right I can't
believe that slipped my mind
should I give you my phone number I
[Music]
think that would be the best yes all
right then
your and I exchanged phone numbers okay
then I'll be stopping by your house on
Sunday yeah my house is that a problem
no not at all I just thought I would be
the one going to your house since I'm
the one helping you I suppose that makes
sense but if you don't mind I would
prefer going to your house all right
in that case it won't be a problem I
decide to not press URI for a reason
it's not like it shouldn't matter much
either way I just need to make sure my
room is clean I hope I manage to make
myself useful in some way I'm not nearly
as creative as you are don't
underestimate yourself pizza pie I think
that will make a very productive team
even if you only choose me because you
felt bad or something wait you don't
actually think that do you
I don't know it's difficult to come up
with any other reason you may have
chosen me
you're forgetting the one reason we have
most common sentient with the most
common sense I chose to help you because
that's what I want to do but URI thinks
to herself with an extremely tense
expression URI you're overthinking this
you wanted me to point out when you're
overthinking right yeah I didn't realize
I'm telling you I want to that's all
there is to it
do you believe me hi URI things really
hard again she looks straight into my
eyes for a long time
I believe you if it took her tremendous
as if it took tremendous effort URI
finally says that and relaxes our
expression I'm really looking forward to
Sunday yeah I am too after that exchange
I make my way out the door and URI
follows I can't believe this
Yura is going to his gaze ah here it is
coming to be it URI is going to be
coming to my house and Sunday even
though I would have preferred to do this
with saiary my anxiety still shoots
through the roof I guess I gotten pretty
used to handling her at this point but
who knows what may not end up happening
when we're outside of school she even
told me she was looking forward to I
shake my head why do I feel nervous that
say or he finds out about this it's not
like we feel that way about each other
besides like Monica said this is about
the club and I have nothing to worry
about if I just go with it
then I'll have a good time I think I
would still tell Sayuri so she doesn't
feel uncomfortable if she finds out it's
already Sunday a beginning increasingly
anxious I think we should end this
episode here
[Music]
these episodes fly by I'm having so much
fun just reading it I know it's like
very a complete opposite of my content
you know very edited very structured
very where it's trying to like compact
but you can't do that here you have to
read it that's what it's about and but
I'm enjoying it it's really fun and I
hope you enjoy it as well I really
appreciate you tagging along showing
support and that's it see you tomorrow
with another episode squad fam
[Music]